-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden said yesterday
that he was surprised
by the news that
classified documents were found
in his old think tank office,
and added he wasn't sure
what was in the files.
Ah, yes, the ol' "grandpa
caught shoplifting" maneuver.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ]
"Uh-oh, what's that?
There's something in my pocket?
Oh, a Charleston Chew?"
[ Laughter ]
How could that happen?"
[ Normal voice ]
After classified documents
were found in his old
think tank office,
President Biden said yesterday,
"People know I take
classified documents,
classified information
seriously."
He then added, "Even the aliens
at Area 51 know that. Damn it!"
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
presided over
a closed-door meeting yesterday
of the Republican Conference,
but they eventually let him in.
[ Laughter ]
C-SPAN formally
requested yesterday
that House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
allow the network's
independent cameras
to cover the Chamber,
though McCarthy says
they first have to weigh
an offer from TMZ.
[ Laughter ]
The Rules Package approved
by the House this week
included a measure that would
allow members to cut salaries
of individual Federal employees.
Said Biden, "What the hell?!"
[ Laughter ]
How am I gonna afford
my Charleston Chews?!"
[ Laughter ]
According
to Financial Disclosures,
Georgia Republican Senate
nominee Herschel Walker
has more than $5 million
left in his campaign account,
though, needless to say,
someone should probably
check the math.
[ Laughter ]
The Golden Globe Awards
were held last night,
and former child star
Ke Huy Quan
won best supporting actor
for his role in "Everything --"
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Everything Everywhere
All at Once."
I mean, what a comeback story.
I honestly never thought
we would see
the Golden Globes again.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
the average teenager
is first exposed
to online pornography
by 12 years old,
despite the strict controls
in place to stop it.
[ Laughter, applause ]
It seems foolproof.
[ Laughter ]
On this day in 1935,
pilot Amelia Earhart
made the first
successful solo flight
from Hawaii to California,
and I think we can all agree
it made her
a little too confident.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
And finally, a 9-year-old
in Maryland recently found
a tooth of an extinct
megalodon shark,
and this is weird,
in a McNugget.
You guys...
[ Laughter ]
...that was a mo--
that was a monologue.